welcome back to New rockstars I'm Hector
Navarro and today I'm talking about
something very very exciting a brand new
book now hang on this is a book you
nerds will actually care about so stick
with me here look out for the little guy
by Scott Lang fictional character from
the MCU and author of this now very real
book we saw Scott talking about his
Memoir and Ant-Man and the wasp
quantumania and Scott's book tour was
even briefly mentioned at the bottom of
a news ticker under Anderson Cooper in
Black Panther wakanda forever linking
the events of those two films is
happening around the same time the
spring and summer of 2025. so what is
this book well it's a first-hand account
written from the perspective of Ant-Man
himself of the events spanning Ant-Man
Captain America Civil War Ant-Man and
the wasp and Avengers end game with a
little extra stuff before in between and
after those movies what was basically
just a movie prop for Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania is now a real book you
can buy and read and gift to your MCU
loving friends and surprisingly it's
also a pretty great self-help book I
can't can't believe the MCU has now also
given us a self-help book just like how
Rogers the musical was designed as a
joke at first but then ended up being
kind of earnest look out for the little
guy may have started as an in-movie joke
but because the character of Scott Lang
is a former convict and a dad who really
loves his daughter and family there are
genuine moments of warmth and heroism
and positive thinking wrapped up in all
the funny stuff I found myself nodding
along multiple times while reading and
thinking to myself yeah I really gotta
apply that mindset to my life more so
way to go Scott and the fun thing is we
learn a little bit more about the MCU
from Scott and the various Avenger
characters he talks to for the book so
I'm gonna tell you all the fun stuff we
learned and maybe give you a little life
advice along the way just do me a favor
and go get the book yourself if you're
even a little interested it's a fun and
Breezy read and it might change your
life plus it really sounds like Paul
Rudd as Scott Lang so kudos to probably
real writer Rob cutner who's credited in
the acknowledgments in the back as
Scott's writing coach cheerleader late
night texture transcriber and occasional
crying partner you killed it Rob first
question answered how did Scott decide
to write this book well according to him
it wasn't his idea it was The Avengers
idea specifically Bruce Banner and Clint
Barton who take Scott out to lunch and
tell him they think the World At Large
should know the specific details of what
went down during the blip and how they
defeated Thanos and that Scott is the
perfect guy to do it because he's the
Everyman Avenger Clint tells Scott
you're the guy who got scooped up in all
this pretty recently you still got one
foot in their world and you're a guy
Everyone likes and trusts then Bruce
says it's tough stuff and no one knows
how to keep it light like you it's my
Mark Ruffalo impression it makes sense
that they'd pick Scott to do this
considering Banner is a Super Genius
Hulk no longer really a part of the
normal human world and Barton went off
the deep end in those five years and
became a vigilante assassin Scott really
is the Everyman Avenger this might also
kind of explain why Scott later made a
podcast appearance that Kamala Khan Ms
Marvel was a listener of because Scott
is taking it upon himself to share
Insider Avenger knowledge with the world
then after learning that Scott asked Dr
Strange about his 14 million 605
potential alternate lives because who
wouldn't be curious but strange didn't
tell him anything Scott commits to
writing the book and plans to talk about
his life along with Avengers history so
just like in quantumania we get the
sense that maybe Scott is building
himself up a little bit throughout the
book boosting his own ego and not taking
full credit but definitely mentioning
his key role in Saving the universe and
bringing everyone back from the blip a
lot which means we might have an
unreliable narrator on our hands but
that's okay it fits Scott's inflated ego
at the beginning of quantumania so that
when he gets confronted by Kang the
Conqueror in that story it shakes Scott
to his core one thing we can rely on is
being true is that Scott admits he just
wants people to ask him to take a
picture with their dog which explains
that genuine smile when he finally gets
asked that at the beginning of
quantumania so I'm going to try and lay
out everything in chronological order
starting with a fun detail we learn
about Hank Pym when he was first testing
out the ant communication technology he
invented it didn't go exactly according
to plan and he was almost killed on a
shrunken journey to his backyard ant
hill hope Van Dyne recounted this to
Scott when he was training to be Ant-Man
in 2015 saying that her dad told her if
it wasn't for a bigger centipede that he
and the Ants had to work together to
defeat he might have been killed by the
ants themselves this feels like a
reference to Tales to astonish number 35
the first appearance of Hank Pym wearing
the Ant-Man costume in the comics and
where he had to take down a beetle not a
centipede but still it's fun to imagine
a young Michael Douglas living out some
of those early Ant-Man comic book
Adventures they're great cut to 2012
where Scott and the rest of the world
was witnessing the events of the first
Avengers movie and then after that is
when Scott first learned about the
crimes his company San Francisco Tech
Giant Vista Corp were committing this
all tracks because according to a 2015
episode of whih news front hosted by
Christine Everhart we know that Scott
had been in prison for 3 three years
placing his arrest and imprisonment in
2012. what might be a new revelation
though is that according to Scott he and
his ex-wife Maggie's marriage was
already over before Scott got arrested
he also deeply regrets not telling
Maggie his plans to commit the crime to
break into vistacorp to refund regular
people their stolen money back this
self-reflection now affects how Scott
acts in his relationship with hope
sharing everything in his life with her
which is what we should all be doing
with our partners so take that life
advice to heart this information from
Scott also lines up with the Ant-Man
Prelude comic Scott Lang Small Time MCU
infinite comic number one where Scott
learned about vistacorp told Maggie but
then didn't tell her he was going to do
something about it yay continuity while
in prison we learned that Scott took up
gardening to keep himself busy focusing
on a three by six foot patch of grass he
would later reapply that kind of mental
focus to his house arrest from 2016 to
2018. the other new information about
Scott during his time in prison is that
instead of trying to pick fights with
the toughest guys in the yard he asks
them when their birthdays were and
actually sang to them on that date why
because people still wanted to be
treated like full human beings in prison
and Scott became the guy getting along
with everybody in there more great life
advice to consider in the book there's
also maybe a reveal that Scott Lang's
mom is alive and disappointed in him
being Ant-Man but it could have also
just been for a bit Scott tends to crack
jokes after all that's kind of his thing
but back in 2015 after he's released
from prison the events of the first
Ant-Man movie take place and we learn a
little bit more about what happened from
Scott's point of view also I don't know
how vital this information is but I
thought it was hilarious apparently Hank
Pym trained an aunt to take photos for
them to document their training and
their use for the book and Scott says
they call him Aunt Soul Adams great and
we learned that Scott did more training
with ants after his successful Mission
into Avengers compound and Darren cross
visiting Hank Pym later that night look
out for the little guy puts the events
of Captain America Civil War immediately
after the events of Ant-Man where hope
and Hank were just beginning to trusts
Scott and then Scott goes and takes the
Ant-Man suit without asking to help cap
in Germany this doesn't exactly line up
with what we know about the MCU timeline
where Ant-Man takes place in the summer
of 2015 and Civil War took place in May
of 2016 almost a year later but maybe
Scott is talking about how the months in
between these movies felt like they were
happening right on top of each other
with the pims just barely beginning to
trust Scott before he runs off with
Clint Barton Hawkeye in an interview
that Scott conducts with her hope Van
Dyne describes in detail what she was
going through at the time emotionally
and mentally and how Scott didn't really
know about that growing up with Hank Pym
as a father having all of his incredibly
important work almost be taken away from
them because of Scott's decision to
break the law again forcing her and her
father Hank on the run and then two
years later hope sees her mother again
alive after decades thinking that she
was dead but then Scott says hope
doesn't have to go through it alone and
he's there for her and she for him 200
percent which is the amount we should
all strive to be present for our
partners as well see that's just great
life advice
One-Shot energy huh okay I'll try it
oh yeah
[Applause]
whoa what does one shot's Focus chew do
[Music]
hey Charlie
whoa one shot really is all you need
begin your transformation with one shot
energy today by going to
oneshotenergy.com new rockstars for 10
off your order during his house arrest
Scott kept in touch with friends and
loved ones with video conferencing
technology and the book makes a joke
that maybe that sort of thing will catch
on one day he also lists off the various
cardboard attractions that he made to
entertain his daughter Cassie while
being stuck at home like a cardboard
roller coaster cardboard robot war a
cardboard pony ride and probably a very
bad idea a cardboard water park and
hypothetically Scott says he once used
PIN particles to enlarge a jelly donut
for Cassie at his house hypothetically
new info here Scott reveals it hope Van
Dyne can control the shrinking and
growing feature of her suit with her
mind and controls in her helmet whereas
Scott still has to use buttons to
activate those abilities next is a
chapter called Infinity Saga Abridged
which is perfect Scott describes what
was going through his head after
escaping the quantum realm in 2023 and
reuniting with his daughter Cassie she
was the one who had to tell Scott what
happened Scott says they spent the night
looking at a photo album quote pouring
over the endless smiling faces of people
who suddenly got yanked out of our Lives
Maggie Paxton Louise Kurt Dave we still
don't know if the Ant-Man Supporting
Cast was dusted or not but considering
luis's van was impounded I'm leaning
towards Luis at least being gone for
those five years speaking of that van
Scott then drove it all the way to
Avengers compound and Steve Rogers and
Natasha Romanov had to explain to Scott
exactly what had happened after they let
him in they tell Scott about Thanos
collecting the Infinity Stones before
the snap and Scott didn't even know
there was a snap he just knows of The
Disappearance event as the blip giving
us more insight into how much the
general public knew about what happened
this is again probably part of the
reason the other Avengers later wanted
someone to share this information with
the public Steve and Nat give some
updates to Scott about the rest of the
Avengers like how Bruce Banner was in
Mexico and that Tony visited him which
we heard about in She-Hulk attorney at
law and that last they heard Thor was in
new Asgard which was true we hear this
entire conversation between the three of
them before catching us right back up to
that scene in end game where Steve asks
Scott are you okay have either of you
guys ever studied quantum physics only
to make conversation that's all in the
book and the fact that Scott Lang has a
pretty amazing recall for these
conversations makes sense they're some
of the most important interactions Scott
has ever had I would also remember every
single word Captain America and Black
Widow told me next is learning about
what Scott went through during his
experiments with Hulk in time travel we
get a snippet of that in quantumania in
the car where we here and in that moment
all I could think was how did the Hulk
turn me into a baby am I the Hulk's baby
which was hilarious but I found a
potential error in the printed book
where the next words don't match up to
what we hear in the car scene but I was
ready for it this is the radio
lines are missing from the book but
don't worry Marvel Studios you can send
me a famous Marvel no prize because I
have found a way to reconcile this
inconsistency Scott was listening to an
early version of the audiobook before
the book was edited for the final print
version which is why there are a few
lines that didn't make the cut in the
final printed book boom done so then the
rest of the events of Avengers end game
are described from Scott's point of view
including that hilarious moment we heard
about in the car in quantumania where
Scott says a little after that a raccoon
from space showed up I don't think he
knew my name I was just happy to meet a
raccoon who could talk in the movie we
sort of hear the audiobook in a
different order than the passages in the
book actually are but it's okay because
Scott was probably skipping around not
just fast forwarding when he was trying
to make his daughter Cassie laugh so we
know how genuinely excited Scott was to
meet someone who mostly operated in
space rocket that it's understandable to
learn that Scott was a bit disappointed
that his assigned mission in the Time
Heist traveling to an alternate reality
of New York in 2012 was the only one
that wasn't in space because Asgard in
2013 and Morag and vormir in 2014 were
all in space plus not that we needed it
but this book offers yet another
confirmation that the Time Heist in end
game wasn't time travel up and down the
MCU secret timeline but rather travel to
different timelines alternate realities
so it's confirmed that Steve Rogers
ended up in an alternate reality where
he retired with a Peggy Carter not
hidden behind the scenes retired this
entire time with the sacred timelines
Peggy I'm sorry it's a bummer but it's
true a great meta reference during this
section is where Scott details how the
Tesseract they were supposed to steal
ends up being stolen by who he calls alt
2012 Loki and that one can only imagine
what that led to referencing the events
of Loki season 1 where we saw exactly
what that led to also Lang interviewed
other Avengers to get specific details
on the Time Heist and Clint Barton
Hawkeye reveals a lot of what happened
on vormir before Black Widow sacrificed
herself for the Soul Stone Barton
believes it was him saying tell my
family I love him that cemented
romanov's decision to sacrifice herself
and spare Clint and I'm hoping we see
future installments of the MCU like
maybe the upcoming Thunderbolts movie
have characters acknowledge this book
look out for the little guy Natasha's
sister Yelena belova never really got
the specifics of what happened to her
sister and maybe she can refer to having
read this book in a future MCU
installment it's also interesting to
re-experience this part Scott describing
the fourth only ever time he went giant
to save rocket and Roadie from Avengers
compound collapsing on them with the
knowledge that James roads here might
have been a scroll named rava the book
also makes a point to explain why Scott
Lang didn't pass out after being giant
man during the Battle of Earth for a few
reasons one Scott was in better shape
two Scott's adrenaline overrode his
emotions three Scott was fighting on the
side of Heroes not against and maybe
most importantly that four he finally
knew when to stop being big unlike in
Germany and the San Francisco Bay then
we read about Hope coming back and Hearn
Scott reuniting then another great joke
at the mcu's expense Scott describes
then we all heard it the tiny but
somehow audible to thousands command of
Captain America Avengers Assemble fans
have asked how all those assembled
Heroes could have heard caps whisper
across the battlefield and here you have
Ant-Man explaining that they somehow
just did maybe kamartaj's Wizards were
handing out earpieces as they portaled
around the universe Gathering Heroes but
that's just my take on it I'll happily
take a second no prize though Marvel
happily then even Scott couldn't believe
luis's van survived the battle so far he
later learned from the WASP who Captain
Marvel was when she came in and in one
of the most heartbreaking sections of
the Memoir Scott reminds the reader that
Tony Stark was also a father who gave up
a life with his daughter Morgan so that
everyone else could be reunited with
their loved ones so after end game Scott
hangs out with Luis and there is no
confirmation one way or the other that
Luis was around during the blip five
years or not but Luis doesn't do what
everyone wants him to do and sum up the
events of the MCU since Ant-Man and the
WASP instead he rattles off possible
scenarios of Scott Lang's life had he
made different decisions at crucial
moments in his life which is really fun
bring back Luis y'all he's great come on
bring him back and hear post endgame
Scott mentions that Clint Barton has his
hands full with his family and a new
Protege which means that Scotland was
writing the book during or after the
events of Christmas in 2024. Scott also
describes some Adventures that he and
the WASP went on that we didn't see
which makes sense after end game the
Kick-Ass Duo of crime Fighters are
finally reunited so of course they're
going to keep being Ant-Man and the WASP
now Scott's family is tired of hearing
about his superhero stuff might be
another reason he wrote the book to get
it all down on paper and spare them from
hearing him talking about being an
Avenger and another interesting
confession is that Scott admits things
between him and teenage daughter Cassie
are complicated setting up the character
development between them both in
quantumania but just like that film this
book has Scott reflecting on how much
time he's lost with Cassie and there's
also a possible meta joke about Scott
being surprised what decade of Life he's
already in maybe a reference to actor
Paul Rudd's seeming immortality and
Scott at one point also mentions how
Janet Van Dyne refuses to talk about her
time in the quantum realm again setting
up the events of quantumania rather
nicely another fun detail about the book
is that at one point Scott says with
almost 100 certainty that the quantum
realm doesn't include intelligent life
forms we all know how that worked out so
yes we get to the end of the book and
it's pretty much exactly like the
opening narration of quantumania with
some extra lines added in between what
Scott is saying to the audience in the
movie also gotta point out that the
actual book's back cover is similar but
different to the book back cover we see
in the movie and that brings us up to
the events of Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania so there you have it folks
all the fun new MCU details we learned
from Reading Scott Lang's new book my
next question is full Paul Rudd
audiobook version when I mean it's not
like he's doing anything else right
because of the strikes so pay him fairly
and get this sucker recorded Disney
Marvel my next next question is what
other MCU novel would you like to see
Marvel Studios publish next here's my
pitch a decades-long account of the
Sacred timelines Steve Rogers and his
life in the alternate reality where he
stayed with Peggy Carter where he
undoubtedly changed his world for the
better did he go and find Bucky
immediately build relationships with the
people of wakanda sooner prep the world
for the incoming chatari and Thanos
threats you bet you're America's ass he
did and I want to read all about it so
please go get your copy of Scott's new
book so that Marvel can keep bringing us
new MCU stories in new formats and try
to find the fun detail about Black Widow
that I left out of the breakdown let me
know in the comments below if you think
you found it follow me over at Heroes
reforged on YouTube see you next time
and remember if there's one thing life's
taught me there's always room to grow
[Music]
foreign